hi I'm former NASA astronaut scott kelly
and today i'm gonna answer some of your
questions on twitter the first one is
from Dirk so what is the speed of the
ISS well the ISS is in low-earth orbit
and things in low-earth orbit are
travelling generally at a speed of
around 17,500 miles per hour which is 25
times the speed of sound so really
really fast since C next question from
Cece Takato with the people on the
International Space Station be able to
see the effects of the eclipses well we
are traveling in orbit around the earth
we orbit the Earth every 90 minutes so
if you were in the right place at the
right time you would see a big black
spot over the earth which is the shadow
from the moon on this last Eclipse we
had the astronauts were able to get a
picture of it and it was it was really
impressive next question if I died in a
spacesuit and was released to drift
through space would I decompose or just
be a floating corpse forever asking for
a friend
yes you would decompose rather quickly
it would I think quickly get kind of not
too Pleasant in microgravity and I'm not
exactly sure why but things seem to
decompose much quicker but if you were
in low-earth orbit and you were doing a
spacewalk from the space station and
drifted away eventually you would you
would re-enter the earth to be you know
a shooting star hopefully your friends
would be able to see you I miss Scott
Kelly's tweets from space me too and is
that flower still growing up there when
I was on board the space station we grew
some stuff in space we grew some lettuce
and after that we grew something a
little bit more complex which was
flowers zinnias the idea is if we can
grow a flower maybe we can grow a tomato
and eventually going to Mars we could
use that as nutrition unfortunately you
know I had to harvest those flowers and
send them back to earth
I actually have one at home pressed into
a book but they we've grown other stuff
since then and
and our plan is to continue to try to
grow more complicated stuff
unfortunately space flower is no longer
with us let's see next question how many
times do you think someone on the bridge
of the space shuttle said punch it
Chewie when the launch sequence started
I would imagine for launch because it's
so complicated risky incredible
experience that I would guess zero time
someone said punch it Chewie but you
never know if I was flying this actually
wouldn't say punch it Chewie because
it's not the Millennium Falcon Chewie
wasn't in here I'd say punch it r2d2
he's right there okay from Jason Garcia
planned on sleeping tonight but now it's
5 a.m. and googling quote how do
astronauts make new oxygen up in a space
station for years I need answers well
Jason I have answers on the space
station we have a few ways of making
oxygen one is we use a process called
electrolysis so we take water this was a
water molecule we would have one big
hydrogen to smaller o two modules or I'm
sorry I messed that up this is the O and
these are the h's the two little ones
are the HS electrolysis will will
separate the two H's from the O and with
another o we can create Oh two two
oxygen molecules like this
oxygen which we then breathe of course
if you're in the International Space
Station what time is it this isn't a
riddle I'm genuinely genuinely curious
how they keep time
so we're orbiting the Earth every 90
minutes so we have a sunrise and a
sunset either or every 45 minutes
generally speaking and we have these
control centers that are that are all
around the earth we have in Houston and
Huntsville Alabama Cologne Germany
Moscow and in a place called scuba Japan
you know we need a standard of time of
course
so we operate on Greenwich Time and the
reason we chose Greenwich Time was
because the people that work in the
control center in Moscow most of them
have to get to work on the Moscow subway
they don't really have an option to
drive or walk or ride a bike so the time
we use Greenwich Time was very conducive
to the folks in Moscow using the Metro
which is not open 24 hours a day so
that's why we use grant time because of
the subway schedule in Russia is
suspended animation a viable option for
space travel say the planets like Mars
we're further well I think when we go to
Mars the way we're gonna get there is
gonna probably take around 200 days to
get there you'll spend a year on the
surface and I'll take around 200 days to
get back now certainly if our technology
improves you could potentially get there
faster so I think for Mars it's not
really something that's necessary you
know if you were gonna go to Jupiter or
Saturn the moons of Jupiter or Saturn or
even further away and it's gonna take
many many years to get there in many
many years to get back if you could
develop a technology like suspended
animation that would be really really
good but I'm not sure if anyone's
actually working on that I think at this
point that might be more you know
science fiction and science fact but you
never know we'll see any physical mental
residual effects that are still with you
after your year in space I don't think
so
as at least as far as I could tell which
you know I don't have any symptoms I
don't have physical symptoms of being in
space for a long period of time mental
issues I don't know I probably deny it
if I did but then there are the things
that you can't see like when I was on
the space station I got a lot of rage
for instance perhaps there are effects
from that that I don't even know about
and hopefully I'll never find out I
don't think just a simple question could
astronauts hold their breath in space
instead of wearing the whole uniform no
you couldn't do that without any
atmospheric pressure out in space all
the gases that are in solution in our
blood they come out of solution and turn
back into a gas kind of like when you
open a carbonated bottle of soda the
pressure is decreased and that's why you
see all the bubbles coming out that's
exactly what would happen with our blood
if we didn't have a spacesuit on which
would kill us within a few minutes not
to mention without the pressure holding
your breath would be really hard you
ever wonder what happens to your your
organs in space like other floats
around do your organs float around your
body or that everything floats including
your guts you can feel that I mean you
could feel like your insides don't feel
quite normal
certain you know processes that we have
to deal with every day particularly you
know using the restroom takes time
because our body likes to have gravity
telling us which direction to push stuff
so when everything's floating including
your organs and everything inside you it
creates some challenges also the blood
floats inside us and that's why you see
at times astronauts in space have really
big their heads are swollen initially
because all the fluid is redistributed
throughout our bodies and you get this
big head at astronaut you know
eventually you get rid of some of that
fluid and you go back to maybe almost
looking like normal next question what
was the most exciting or fascinating
science experiment you conducted in your
year in space it's kind of hard to
choose you know I would I would offer
two experiments one was we did some
experiments with rodents where we
dissected them and we we appreciated
them giving their lives to us for
science and that science was involved in
understanding the physical effects that
occur when we're in space like bone
effects on our vision which we have some
negative effects we're trying to study
yeah that was challenging I would say
fascinating sort of exciting because
it's very meticulous work that takes a
really long time and it's important to
us on earth understanding processes that
occur in space at a very rapid rate very
similar to how we age on earth we lose
bone mass muscle mass as we age but in
space it happens much more rapidly the
other experiment that I really liked was
the the flowers that we grew I think
it's very very relatable to people on
earth and also has implications for
exploration as we go further out in the
space having living things I think it'll
also help from you know psychological
aspect so you know those two growing
plants and working with the rodents were
for me the most exciting or fascinating
science experiment that I did in my year
in space you know how people get
vacation blues how two astronauts cope
with coming back to Earth after seeing
space it's not easy you know when when
you get back from space after you know
working there for either short or a long
time you generally miss it but you I
think you deal with it like people deal
with every thing that is a challenge in
your life you know you appreciate the
experience you had and then you move on
one of my former astronaut colleagues
you cannot eat padalka he says when we
are on earth we miss space and on morons
when we're in space we miss earth you
definitely miss space when you're back
on earth maybe someday I'll get to go
again maybe with you Lenny that was our
last question and thank you for your
attention and thank you for all the
great questions